once again congratulations I am
immensely proud to stand before you
today the Carnegie Mellon University
graduating class of 2018
this afternoon I see thousands of new
graduates ready to turn their passion
creativity and fearlessness into a
lifetime of societal impact personal
fulfillment and professional success
during your time here you have each made
an indelible mark on this community
you learned deeply and daily inside and
outside the classroom you built a
community rooted in empathy inclusion
and respect forging connections that
will last a lifetime you engage in
creative collaborations with faculty
students across the campus you embraced
our celebration of Carnegie Mellon's
fiftieth anniversary and you each found
ways to be CMU founders your community
service and engagement raise funds and
brought awareness to societal issues you
also shined a light on the ways that our
own community could do better
you brought passion and thoughtfulness
to everything you did whether it was
building a Hyperloop or a moon arc you
can co-op it's okay
shining your talent onstage in a gallery
or through a hackathon creating new
frontiers in artificial intelligence
transition design or material science
[Applause]
and yes even advocating to free the you
see stones you're gonna have to tell
your parents what that means later okay
you were instrumental in attracting a
record enrollment of women and the
largest number of application in the
history of this university through your
example you made a community others want
to join I want to thank you for making
CMU better now it's your time to unleash
your extraordinary energy and skills on
the vast opportunities ahead of you it's
tradition for the President to deliver a
charge to the graduates at the
commencement ceremony one final set of
instructions for how to maximize the
power of your newly minted CMU degree in
reality you won't find a better example
for living CMU's mission and values than
the career of our keynote speaker David
Tepper so listen to everything that he
said
so knowing that I stand alone I alone
stand between you and graduating parties
I will keep my charge brief the
incomparable CMU professor herb Simon
once said we're not spectators of the
future we are actors of the future you
may be wondering how exactly you've
become an actor of the future while I
don't have all the answers I'll offer
three guiding principles to help you
embrace professor Simon's philosophy
first be relentless in your pursuit of
knowledge being educated does not simply
mean getting a degree and then sitting
back rather it requires that you
constantly rekindle the fire of your
curiosity and stay engaged in the
evolution of new ideas do not be afraid
to expand your horizons when the
landscape shifts beneath you make the
world your classroom your canvas and
your stage told you is gonna be short
too second seek out perspectives other
than your own by exploring different
identities and experiences you will
create better ideas and it's stronger
solutions all along the way you will
encounter ideas that challenge you even
if you consider those ideas wrong or
even offensive the remedy is not less
conversation but more
ideas are not defeated by suppression
they're defeated by better more
persuasive ideas I urge you to embrace
and defend the free exchange of ideas
this is the foundation of our democracy
my third piece of advice brings the
previous two together
the global citizens thinking and acting
globally is not something that can be
taught but rather a mindset that's
developed and cultivated over a lifetime
being a global citizen means adopting a
wide view of the world and your role in
it
it means thinking critically acting
entrepreneurial working collaboratively
and responding with empathy and
responsibility to humanity's most
pressing challenges global citizenship
also depends on deep understanding of
the connections that linked us to one
another
think about all the people that have
contributed to your success today
whether directly or indirectly yes the
professors coaches directors advisors
friends and family members but also the
philanthropists like David Tepper who
chose to invest in generations of
students like you don't forget to enrich
the lives of others in the same way and
create opportunities for those who
follow you class of 2018 you all possess
the training and intellect to be
impactful actors of the future I am
truly excited for you and I'm excited
for the future which you hold in your
hands thank you for allowing me to share
this moment with you and on behalf of
the entire CMU community congratulations
class of 2018
you